the u.s government has slapped charges
on tech giant google
it's accused of violating laws meant to
stop monopolies on
online searches and advertising the
lawsuit is one of the most
significant legal challenges to a tech
company in decades
google's conduct is illegal under
traditional antitrust principles and
must be stopped
google has long been the gatekeeper to
the internet with monopolies in general
search
and search advertising these are the
cornerstones of his trillion dollar
empire
google unlawfully maintains these
monopolies through a web of exclusionary
and interlocking agreements
that shut out competitors on that issue
of monopoly actually it's thought google
holds 88
of the us search market with 94 of
all mobile searches occurring on its
services
washington also alleges that the tech
company suppresses innovation by locking
up distribution through contracts with
apple
political analyst dave perkins says this
looks a lot like history
repeating itself i want to compare it to
historically
to the advent of the widespread use of
the telephone in america about a hundred
years ago
when the company called american
telephone and telegraph owned everything
including the manufacturing of the
equipment so government
let that ride for about 50 years and the
prices got too high and the service got
too bad and so
they filed a lawsuit against a t an
anti-trust suit
and it resulted in a t breaking up into
regional
companies and telephone service being
opened up to competitors
and all of that made life much much
better for business and
for american citizens now we have google
which is
considerably more complicated than a
telephone
number one because we're not quite sure
what they're doing
when you use the company services for
free and you can't figure out
what they do to make money and what
their product is that means the product
is you
and they're selling you and your data
and we just don't know how
certainly it should not be done behind
closed doors under cover of darkness
by only one company well for its part
google believes the lawsuit is deeply
flawed and will only hurt consumers by
pushing them
to in its opinion of course inferior
rivals
people use google because they choose to
not because they're forced to
or because they can't find alternatives
this lawsuit would do nothing to help
consumers
to the contrary it would artificially
prop up lower quality search
alternatives
raise phone prices and make it harder
for people to get the search services
they want to use
what google has done is built themselves
essentially a couple of different
forms of monopolies within the
marketplace one of them specifically
though
is with the android operating system
which they say
not only has google you know dominance
in terms of being the largest operating
system in the world but defaults that
system
to create google as the search they also
also um
dominate the advertising market for
online advertising as you know
about 80 to 90 percent of all online
advertising goes through directly
through google
and so the idea is that google has used
and optimized its search engine
its android operating system to be able
to create market dominance and it's not
necessarily because
the public loves google so much as it is
the fact that
google has found a way to make
themselves really the the
primary search engine online when it
comes to a mobile device
you